[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
entier bouger le globe
comment il est si zot lé bien des
monnaies mieux marmaille
alors aujourd'hui aux symboles et nous
les à saint paul dans les eaux à la
femme de belley chez marie andré et
pierre positif et maintenant il fait une
petite chute n'est à la mangue alors le
chutney sais quoi et moi on me proposait
de venir et je dois reconnaître vient
allait bien jason plus vite que ça là
allez allez allez
[Musique]
bonjour marie andrée bonjour comment il
est ça va super avez vous même
ça va il fait aller bon bah déjà merci
d'accueillir nous chez oh oui mais c'est
un grand plaisir et une grande joie me
dira mais je vous en prie diamant un
petit peu une nouvelle et belle cause à
effet mais là nous les dans les hauts de
saint-paul lieu dit bel air ou bien eaux
du ruisseau et enfin de quoi il appelle
comme ça depuis toujours c'est mamie
appelle la ferme du bel air c'est parce
que l'endroit il appelle le beller
dacquois voilà est ici bas nous lé là
depuis une quinzaine d'années et ben non
comme le quelque part là était dit déjà
de ses produits quelques canards mais à
côté de canal foot chose à côté de canal
on a les hébergements non à la table
d'hôtes et entre autres on a aussi tout
la transformation donc on est quoi sur
plus attendre
montre moi tout ça s'il te plaît alors
entrer
[Musique]
quand il doit rentrer dans un local
qu'on dit c'est là il faut les habiller
correctement alors monter moi comment
tramway nouvelle haute couture my
attention voilà oui c'est là encore un
petit au big up n'entend donc tonton mai
mais dis moi c'est quoi tous ces petits
beaucoup de toutes les couleurs encore
bon tout n'est pas là mais bon c'est
vrai que mon travail pour les gens d'ici
et on travaille aussi pour ceux qui
veulent manger ici ou qui va l'envoyer
en métropole 6 ans denis de la réunion
en plats cuisinés par exemple c'est la
raison qui fait plaisir tonton que les
là-bas dans le froid à biot mains
puisque le froid commence à s'installer
là bas là où on va y aller un petit coq
massalé comme ça là mais son ton compte
en main c'est le tonton contentant
contentons heureux même n'a beaucoup de
mamans qui a envahi sa pour les
marmailles
après nous les dans le doubs aussi avec
tous les fruits de du marché le
producteur donc tout ça c'est les
producteurs la réunion il y fait et
noonan a la chance d'avoir tous nos amis
pour du cac autour de nous et ils vont à
nous les fraises sont amusés à nana joe
cole et mentaux du crédit local par les
les
dans les villes la viande
m voilà bon là l émission de fusion
commencer les enfants ça ne fait que
commencer
voilà droite non maintenant nous ça va
dans la cuisine où tu veux nous faire tu
vas nous prépare les quoi exactement
voilà là aujourd'hui on va préparer un
chapelet de mangue carotte parce que
c'est pas avec les membres
josée ann neurol kg 10 euros le kilo
qu'on va les préparer à chaque naissance
et mon travail et callen carotte qui est
là manque de bases de la réunion comme
dimanche se tenait alors c'est quoi
exactement c'est une confiture c'est un
accompagne cette préparation aigre douce
qui va accompagner ou bien sympa
compagnon moi je vends beaucoup pour le
foie gras en fin d'année en fin d'année
les gens ils achètent pour soi gras et
dans tout le courant de l'année ça c'est
aussi pour soi g et pour les grillades
grillades de poisson grillades de
viandes grillades de saucisses
ça fait le petit abri et surtout pour
les gens qui mangent pas trop de piment
par exemple eh ben ça s'accompagne tout
le temps tout mais tu peux faire avec
quoi d'autres comme ananas me confond
avec de l'ananas aussi puis certainement
avec autre chose mais moi ma spécialité
c'est la maman parce que j'aime et je ne
fais que ce que j'aime
voilà donc non sinon bien et comme moi
j'adore le châtiment
alors je fais à l'amande mois déjà
parfois je fais un peu d'ananas aussi
mais bon quand tu fais ça l'est vraiment
donc là là c'est les ingrédients on va
dire principaux pour faire taper par la
cdu la poutargue of d'accord lassé du
gingembre quatre ans de retard et
cannelle 1 et steve et de badiane et
j'ai géré en direct il suppose que non à
des petits ce creed 2 et ses secrets
après c'est au feeling assez au goût aux
siens et puis oui c'est sûr que chacun a
sa méthode mais les gens après ils
choisissent ils vont chez les voilà
c'est à la façon de marion drill voile
donne pas beaucoup seul
sa gamme
[Musique]
pour a besoin de mon mur
non je lis mieux mieux avant carottes
murs a fait ça sera plein de films non
loin du filon que ça on n'a pas besoin
de tout ça deux fils là il faut vraiment
que la moindre restriction d'accord et
puis toute façon il faut quand même son
petit côté l'acide
voilà je suis trop doux voilà c'est de
la grippe sait pas trop d'où ça devienne
confiture la guerre la paix des morts et
qui donne la vie c'était trésor leur
mandat
les crèmes de membres et aussi pour la
cause le matin petit déjeuner
dale prochaine
d'ailleurs des vaches et nous c'est un
nom qui sonne anglais cédé qu'à
l'origine ce bain de ce que me connaît
ni le chapelet il vient de hollande a
les autres pays la appropriée aux autres
un petit peu ça parce que des bons parce
que nous là la recherche dans le monde
des saveurs qui plaisent qui sont
adaptables aussi à nous à nos goûts à
nous regarder un peu de cannelle
maintenant pour la cuisine c'est
important c'est la manière de casser la
cannelle ou avec d'autres choses
m'amuser avec man et anna friel
quand il ya beaucoup quand le producteur
d'ananas tout donne un âne à ce qu'on
fait avec la société quand il ya des
bêtises on fait aussi avec l'éthique
je suis mais ça revient plus cher c'est
tous deux des pistes comme ça alors
c'est hallucinant comme ils sont
vraiment bons et le mélange en fait qui
fait ressortir mais qui sait elle tout
seul serait pas en réalisant canaux tout
giro et anis étoilé
alors où avec diamants de toute façon
avait déjà préparé des manques pas cela
m'a fait mal c'est ce qu'espère ben oui
pour ces deux tons donc là elle a été
super gentil elles apprennent en avance
1 comme ça voilà comme ça ça nous plus
tard ajouté tout ce qu on a besoin voilà
maintenant sur la mesure
est-ce qu'on a un autre pour m tout va
aller en même temps et aussi du sud
on a oublié dessus comme nature aussi
qu'on oblige le sucre et le sucre et si
c'est important de juge quand même de
l'aigre-doux donc la mangue n'apporte
son acidité mais nous on amène de
secours le la peau de tango d'abord moi
tu parles de la pluie tombe ou
ou pour que la peau alors vraiment le
tango déjà il n'a pas beaucoup de peau
blanche la psy sa mère finit il n'a pas
beaucoup de ça mais ça comprend encore
au lieu de roche est d'accord pour
mettre le gingembre et les épices les
pis c'est selon la presse et voilà vous
laisse un petit peu au cas où le
meilleur niveau
nous on n'a pas cette année mais ça peut
[Musique]
devenir des ondes ajoute le réseau
insectes on va attendre comment oovoo
connais que la cuisson les bons bat déjà
tous les monstres armes au liban
cela est dû à la nature il faut que tu
te le mélange les sons que tout est là
bien mélanger qui reste des morceaux
bien sûr parce que c'est ce qui fait la
beauté du chapitre qui reste des
morceaux dedans mais que les ramolli et
que tous les épices a fini
puis il mélangeait avec en oeuvre
[Musique]
sotoba quitter puis les plats cités
mamaï mais sautant bar mode la ferme et
les ramones tizac mais saute en bas n'a
trop pour - trafic en poule k
sautant
autant les
apprendre
des deux verres mais demain on va dès
aujourd'hui la blessure le petit kiosque
avec une vie terrible
dis moi comment elle arrive à là c'est
mon terroir essien on affame il est
d'ici mais mal à ma renault martonas
réunion en 2002 et depuis ben on s'est
dit bon ben ça très cool tu fais ça tu
étais mon métier donc on va continuer là
on a commencé en 2002 on a fait un
bâtiment avec allemagne des lapins ça
n'a pas marché pour de maladie et tout
ça on l'a changé on l'avait du poulet il
ya eu quelques soucis encore après et on
s'est mis enfin faire du foie gras c'est
là qu'on a trouvé notre voix voilà donc
la base de notre travail derniers mois
c'était le foie gras le canard sous
toutes ses formes
on a fait la table d'hôte pour que les
gens puissent manger sur place
ce que ce qu'on produit donc là du coup
on est une table d'hôte qui fonctionne
les gens viennent manger et les gens qui
sont venus manger nous ont dit mais on
aimerait bien dormir aussi il ya un bon
endroit et du coup on a transformé le
bâtiment d'élevage qui était déjà plus
très utile on l'a transformé en
hébergement depuis bâle et l'onf et
hébergement restauration est produit
dans sommes en plus en plus comme a
remarqué il prend la guitare
ap kayamb est arrivé c'est vraiment aux
anges et silva bois et nana le petit
l'ambiance guitare voir est bien comme
il faut et les compos de marie-andrée se
blesse pour ce que l'on fait le tour oui
nacelle tour mais c'était très agréable
merci de l'accueil est un bijou au
revoir allez c'est bon bon ballon à la
prochaine et bien oublié en chemin sur
comment mais bon il est difficile de
redescendre un peu tout ça ouais bah de
toute manière ou redescendre mais c'est
pour mieux revenir la poste ça parce que
l'éthique est fait mal mais redescend me
laisse tout sauf du bon foie gras dès
que j'avais pas bon cabri
léonie la palène héritage passe la corde
l'avait point un grand dommage
le tout est courte
léonie pleure sur des espoirs tombera
pas dans l'oubli cabri sous la halle a
franchement me sens encore le plus petit
goût de mme anglade ans monte dans ma
bouche là c'est nous c'est bon c'est
sucré donc je vous dis au revoir à la
prochaine et on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge
pas du tout parce que moi comme il
rentre dans l'auberge et mamies sont pus
mammites doté à la mi match et à la mi
festival mais tranquille terme
[Musique]